if you haven't gone to sit with a trauma
counselor which is different than grief
I'll recommend you doing that even if
it's two or three
sessions and probably what it will be is
you laying down like on a massage table
or you sitting down in a
chair and the counselor sitting just
behind you or right next to you and you
go back to being
19 about 3 months after you heard about
the diagnosis and then your dad wants to
goes to take you somewhere and he
forgets where he's going to take you
yeah and he looks at you with that fear
that dads aren't supposed to look at
their daughters with because dads are
supposed to have it all
together and what the counselor will do
is just simply put her hand on your
shoulder or hold your hand because your
body's got to cycle it out because it's
still holding on to it